Якщо вода по шию, а рятувальних човнів довкола не видно,
в хід ідуть будь-які плавзасоби.
Навіть матраци…
Або ось такі хиткі човни.
Це жителі селища Дубівці Галицького району на Івано-Франківщині.
Вони запрошують знімальну групу DW проїхатися імпровізованим човном.
Замість весел - лопата.
Дивіться! Ось по шию води…
Стихійне лихо брутально втрутилося в налагоджене життя цього далеко не бідного села,
адже багато хто тут працює на заробітках у ЄС.
Дерева в мулі. Мокрі сліди на стінах показують,
до якого рівня цього разу сягнула вода.
Іван Литвин і подружжя Софія та Віктор Коржаки
по кілька разів на день сідають у човен і пливуть до будинків сусідів,
аби дізнатися, чи все в них гаразд,
привозять їм воду, яку в село гелікоптером доставляють рятувальники.
Ми такі собі МНС-ники на своїй вулиці!
Через сильну повень у своїх домівках виявилися заблокованими понад 50 родин.
Здебільшого це літні люди.
Увечері цей чоловік віз їм воду та хліб.
Я вдома чула: мовляв, я тут на даху.
На поді, як у нас кажуть.
Я тут, на поді!
Давай воду, подивися, що в нас там затопило.
У хаті можна рибу ловити.
Мешканців селищ біля ріки Дністер попереджали про небезпеку затоплень,
рекомендували зробити запаси води, їжі, зібрати речі і бути готовими до евакуації.
Проте повінь у Дубівцях сталася вночі.
Ще два дні тому тут був сільський парк та футбольне поле
Уся ця вода з’явилася буквально за годину,
і люди нічого не встигли зробити.
Наш човен ніяк не може в’їхати в цю браму.
Ні! Не заїде!
З подружжям Марією та Іваном Наливайчуками розмовляємо на відстані.
Вони не можуть вийти з будинку вже три дні.
І ночують під дахом.
Драбину кладемо і туди до гори.
Бо в хаті по коліно води!
Подружжя дуже добре пам’ятає останню велику повінь,
що сталася 2008-го року,
коли на Прикарпатті загинуло 30 людей,
а збитки перевищили три мільярди гривень.
Тоді вода сягнула їхніх вікон.
На думку Івана Наливайчука, за 12 років
влада повинна була вжити усіх необхідних протиповеневих заходів,
на які до того ж тоді виділили загалом майже 5 мільярдів гривень.
Безвладдя, бо немає влади - немає держави.
Одні бандюги і злодії!
ому вал не зробили по-людськи!?
Вода звідки вийшла?
І прорвало дамбу!
Бо абияк зробили - гроші розікрали!
Розлючений у Дубівцях не лише Іван.
Населений пункт затопила вода з гірських річок,
на яких  після повеней у 2008-ому побудували дамби.
Але ті не витримали -
на відміну від збудованої ще в радянські часи дамби на річці Дністер.
Мене цікавить, чому тут 10 метрів різниці?
Тут зробили дамбу...
зовсім не там, де треба.
Вода не мала куди сходити!
Перекрили то село! І Веделка , і Липа звідти підтиснули.
То помилка в чому?
Перекрили знизу нас, розумієте? Зробили з села корито
Дамби не укріпляються. Там липа впала,
і дамбу вирвало всю.
Там якщо піде ще одна вода, то піде з цієї сторони.
Спустити воду із затопленої частини села в Дністер виявилося неможливо.
Два дні люди телефонували в різні служби,
вимагали від сільради, рятувальників відкрити шлюз,
але рятувальники не могли заїхати в село,
а в сільраді не знайшли, чим відкривати.
Рятівники-добровольці Іван та Віктор не витримали і самі відкрили шлюз.
Скільки раз дзвонили, мало бути якесь засідання,
мали вирішувати, чи прокопати дамбу, чи не прокопати.
Сказали, що прокопувати в жодному разі, бо кримінальна відповідальність.
А шлюз відкрити - немає як. То що ми мали робити?
Я з цим чоловіком, ми двоє - відкрили цю дамбу.
Взяли лебідку, один чоловік нам дав, ми пірнули і відкрили. От шлюз, як він зараз є.
Рятувальні машини змогли дістатися до Дубівців,
лише коли спала вода навколо селища, і теж почали відкачувати воду.
Ситуації, коли селяни лишилися один на один зі стихією,
на Прикарпатті були далеко непоодинокі.
Ось фото із селища Довге Тисменицького району.
Місцеві повідомили DW, що їх підтоплювало і в 2008-ому,
але відтоді біля села не було збудовано жодних захисних споруд.
У Галицькій райраді DW повідомили,  що збираються
провести інвентаризацію всіх захисних споруд, встановити власників.
У Дубівцях, приміром, селяни вже кілька років не бачили,
щоб хтось опікувався станом дамби.
Крім того, райрада збирається отримати від фахівців водного господарства пропозиції,
пропозиції, як укріплювати дамби, де будувати додаткові.
У райраді переконані, що саме завдяки заходам із берегоукріплення Дністра,
вжитим після 2008-ого року, вода з Дністра у Галицькому районі
підтопила значно менше населених пунктів, ніж 12 років тому.
Цьогоріч більше лиха накоїли гірські річки, що впадають у Дністер.
Фактично, вони становлять зараз більшу проблему для населених пунктів,
тому що саме вони, як правило, розливаються
і починають підтоплювати.
Чи заходи, які були вжиті після 2008-го року, ефективні?
Так, вони достатньо ефективні.
Вони, можливо, недостатні загалом, щоб убезпечити Галицький район
від підтоплень під час повені,
але вони свою функцію виконали.
Повінь на Прикарпатті затопила понад 13000 будинків,
зруйновано близько 400 км автодоріг, пошкоджено 130 мостів.
Три людини загинули. Масштаби руйнацій можуть виявитися більшими, ніж 12 років тому.
За фактом загибелі людей, збитків приватних господарств,
комунальних і приватних підприємств,
може бути порушена не одна кримінальна справа
Створюються групи з встановлення збитків,
шкоди від цієї повені.
Відповідно за результатами будуть дефектні акти.
І в подальшому, якщо є вина певних чиновників, відповідно,
ми будемо виявляти ці факти, проводити слідство
і винних притягати до кримінальної відпо відальності.
Поліцейські пліч-о-пліч з рятувальниками.
Теж відкачують воду з домогосподарств.
Обидві служби переведені на посилений режим роботи -
працюють цілодобово з короткими пееррвами.
Ця машина може відкачувати до 110 літрів на секунду.
ДСНС насамперед відкачує воду з об’єктів соціальної інфраструктури і запевняє,
що в них достатньо ресурсів для ліквідації підтоплення і в приватних господарствах.
Ми вживаємо заходи щодо нарощування сил і засобів.
На даний час ми говоримо про Галицький район.
Нам на допомогу прибули колеги з Волинської області.
Масштаби лиха вже перевищили можливості ДСНС.
Свої ресурси надала Національна гвардія України.
Уряд хоче залучити до робіт і міжнародний інженерний батальйон "Тиса".
Василь Данилюк бідкається: у нього підтопило будинок,
загинули дві бджолині сім'ї і знищено врожай на городі.
Як вони хватанули вологу,
то поки висохне, з них нічого не буде.
Чоловік вважає, що його рідне місто Галич підтопило
не лише через погані дамби чи застарілу каналізацію.
Крадуть! Ніякого порядку.
Я був у горах. Там можна куб лісу купити за тисячу.
Без документів, без нічого.
Ліси менше різати і треба порядок навести.
Масові вирубки лісів у Карпатах вже не вперше називають
однією з причин масштабних повеней у Західній Україні.
Кожна влада обіцяє розібратися з цим.
Проте віз і досі там, нарікає Василь.
Прокуратура Івано-Франківської області розпочала кримінальне провадження за фактом екоциду,
а саме: чи могла призвести до значних паводків на Заході України
незаконна вирубка лісів.